the first season of Star Trek Picard has
reached its epic conclusion as did
Picard himself at least temporarily from
a familiar catchphrase to a surprisingly
sentimental musical callback here are
all the Easter eggs and references you
may have missed in Picard season finale
at in Arcadia ego part 2 after hinting
at it all season narc finally reveals
the full myth that has motivated the zot
Vash for generations the story of ganma
damn it tells the ancient tale of demon
twin sisters who opened a crack in the
sky and rained down destruction upon the
living the tale of ganma Dan is told to
the enthralled crew of La Sirena around
a campfire at night which is reminiscent
of another time on Star Trek that
ancient stories were told around a
campfire in the next generation episode
Darmok the card finds himself stranded
on a planet with the captain of an alien
race who communicates solely through
stories during one scene around a
campfire Picard draws parallels between
the aliens captain's stories of Darmok
and Jalad at Tanagra to the epic of
gilgamesh Gilgamesh a king at the end of
Darmok the alien captain dies but
considers his sacrifice worthwhile since
he was able to establish meaningful
communication with Picard and the
Federation it's similar to how Picard
accelerates his own death at the end of
Picard season finale in the hopes that
he might be able to convince the
Federation the Romulans and the
synthetics to finally listen to one
another we've heard a lot of familiar
phrases from Picard's tenure aboard the
enterprise during the course of Picard's
first season - oh dude however one of
the former captain's most well-known
catchphrases has been notably absent
thank you make it so that's it make it
so however we do finally get to hear
someone say make it so in a 10 Arcadia
ego part - but it's not Picard it's
Agnes while we've had no shortage of
other verbal callbacks in Picard it was
impossible not to wonder if Picard would
ever utter his own best-known command
but although we're still waiting to hear
make it so from Picard's own lips there
was something soothing about finally
getting to hear it from someone as seven
of nine and Nerissa fight on the crashed
Borg cube Nerissa taunts Evan with the
memory of her assimilation saying
sad Queen Annika six years old and all
she called her birthday was assimilated
the taunt calls back to the Star Trek
Voyager episode The Raven in which seven
processes the trauma of her assimilation
during that episode she recounts the day
the Borg attacked her family ship
telling Tuvok that her birthday cake had
six candles on it plus one to grow on
it's a difficult memory for seven to
face but she still refuses to let the
Romulan get the best of her sending
Nerissa to her supposed death the season
finale of Star Trek Picard references
the classic Picard maneuver by name when
Picard and Agnes find themselves facing
off against the Romulan fleet desperate
Agnes asked Picard to come up with a
brilliant plan before realizing that she
can use the synthetic tool ríos acquired
on cap Elias to execute a new form of
the Picard maneuver the Picard maneuver
2.0 involves using synthetic technology
to replicate hundreds of Los arenas in
order to trick the Romulans into
thinking the opposing fleet has already
arrived
of course only the original lost Serina
is real and once the Romulans hit it
with their phasers the illusion falters
still it buys them enough time for the
real reinforcements from Starfleet to
arrive saving the day only time will
tell if Agnes's tactic does indeed get
recorded in the Federation history books
as a new iteration of the Picard
maneuver or whether we may have just
witnessed the first ever use of the
jarate maneuver when Riker shows up at
capella Asst in in Arcadia ego part two
leading the Federation fleet the
flagship he commands is named the
Shanghai this ship is almost certainly
named for Shanghai a Chinese explorer
and diplomat during the early Ming
Dynasty however there is actually been a
Jang hae once before in Star Trek
history though not in any of the shows
or movies the Jang he appears in the
Star Trek online video game as a science
vessel which gets attacked by Gorn
forces while on a research mission
although Riker brings what looks like
every ship in the Federation with him a
net in Arcadia ego part 2 he only needs
to show the Romulans that he means
business when he holds them accountable
to the treaty of Algeron
the Treaty of Algeron dates back to the
Year 2311 it's the agreement that
defined the Romulan neutral zone
prohibited the Federation from
developing their own cloaking technology
and classified any violations of the
neutral zone as an act of war Ryker's
own former commander violated the Treaty
of Alderaan in the
next generation episode the Pegasus in
which they were both arrested for
developing an illegal cloaking device
when Picard briefly joins data in his
afterlife simulation before being
transferred to his new synthetic body
data asks a favor from his former
captain
when Picard wakes up data would like him
to terminate his consciousness not
because he wants to die but because he
thinks that by knowing his existence is
finite he may finally be able to truly
live in data's final moments as Picard
shuts down the simulation he listens to
blue skies which also opened Picard's
first episode this time it's sung by ISA
briones the actor who plays Shoji dodge
and Sutra in Star Trek nemesis data
performs the song for his colleagues so
it's only fitting that his daughter
would sing it over him as he dies the
card also bids farewell to data with a
quote from Shakespeare's The Tempest we
are such stuff as dreams are made on and
our little life is rounded with a sleep
in the play this is a line set by
Prospero a character that data himself
played in the next generation episode
emergence I am NOT certain I fully
understand this Prospero character I
would appreciate any insight you might
have it would improve my performance
Picard explains how hopefulness helps
balance out the tragedy in the character
when data dies for good in Picard those
elements are both present again since
his death was unquestionably sad but
carried with it data's hope of finally
experiencing what it is to be human the
closing moments of at in Arcadia ego
part to show what appears to be a pile
of metal shards sitting on a table
between 7 and Ravi this is actually a
Vulcan game of logic and strategy known
as kal-toh in which the object is to
turn the seemingly random rods into a
perfect sphere Vulcan kalto for a game
of logic you'd be surprised at how
addictive it is kalto was a frequent
pastime for Tuvok on Voyager which he
tended to play with Harry Kim and each
head although it was also possible to
play kalto alone Kim was never able to
beat Tuvok despite numerous attempts but
7 of 9 managed to beat him in a single
move impressive
elementary spatial harmonics check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]